today on our show ladies ladies ladies
that's right man all news stories about
ladies in genre and one story about a
dude who ain't a lady nope in the genre
straight in a romper today Batman Batman
on Batman well in the fat man Batman I'm
Kevin I'm mark barnard all right what
ladies you ask well it's this simple
we're going to talk about three ladies
as a preview Linda Hamilton yes Jamie
Lee Curtis
Sabrina technically lady even though
fictional characters indeed but that's
cool and then the dude is a mystery
who's gonna make you stick around yeah
yeah nah but again looks good to rapper
but first but [ __ ]
hey Selleck owner is back about time
about friggin time let loose Arcana yes
I am she'll be able to say and I'll be
able to say I'm with her Sarah Connor
had her own TV show for a minute she did
indeed but it wasn't this Sarah Connor
you know it was terminated Sarah Connor
Chronicles and this is oh gee Sarah
Connor this is Linda Hamilton's a lady
who originated the role who was a
doe-eyed newcomer in the first one 1984
and then in the second one redesigned
yeah like female lead in a action movie
by buffing up at middle age I think at
that point and stuff like that and she
was was she married to James Cameron she
did get married to James Cameron one
point as did apparently everybody else
who's ever worked with lady G she was
mrs. James Cameron for a long time
taking over from Gale Anne Hurd who was
the original mrs. James Cameron who
worked with the monitor indeed any
aliens and then now she's back she's
back because there's something we never
thought would happen
our boy Tim Miller is making a new
visitor [ __ ] kid Tim ah he's got the
world by the balls
he really does I saw him in 70 ago at
the screen jockeys event we should
chitchat a backstage and he was talking
about like his next thing is the
Terminator movie with Cameron onboard
cameras onboard to co-write and seduce
this guy yeah it's a mellow good heart
mmm good job wait a very direct ER and
one film people like how can you say
that one film [ __ ] I've also seen all
that blur Studios [ __ ] that he different
video games which is brilliant plus like
once enough especially if it's Deadpool
I don't care who made that somebody was
like well Hitler made
well there's a good director who knew
horrible person yeah but the guy you
know just like Wow we'd evolved pretty
quickly Nazis always good to punching
out some people don't like him hmm right
for you know for very for valid reasons
and stuff indeed oh my god this went
dark let's get back into the [ __ ]
story yes back to the future
Terminator the next Terminator movie by
our hero Tim Miller yet to be produced
by terminator creator Jim Cameron well
there is some writer-director Jim
Cameron mm-hmm and now the final piece
of the puzzle is Linda Hamilton and
Schwartz it was also from the door
previously announced which lingers back
and he's in it as well that guy there
you know because we all need to remember
Terminator Genisys which also this movie
will erase that from Norman let's hope
this is the movie that would be honest
with you that like you know you got
Cameron you got Linda Hamilton you got
Arnold and you got this kid Tim Miller
just get to know 52 and I think that
there they are fashioning this as a
direct sequel to 1991's Terminator 2
Judgment Day so they're gonna ignore are
going to ignore terminal error gains
she's no longer part of rise of the
machines and Genesis and just goes away
and salvation was I don't know where
that took place in the universe
meaning it where they're just skipping
right over all that [ __ ] and going
straight to the og team ignoring our
past
I look I'm bitching I can get all those
people involved they know how to make a
soup and that's the soup I wanna drink
you know who else is helping to make the
soup they got a writers room put
together for this particular movie they
got in this writers room along with
Cameron and Miller okay David Goyer oh
he did Westworld I don't know David Gore
did MLA yes he's the Christopher Nolan
Jonah Nolan did Jonathan Nolan he's the
ones of Westworld yes he wouldn't work
on this right cuz he's got his own show
I don't think so
Gloria works on a lot of things he does
he's like Hollywood's go to lunch on her
screenwriter yeah let's see Charles
eglee who created Dark Angel with James
Cameron and also on the theme what
studio this is for sky dancers producing
with that Josh Friedman who wrote war
the world's first Spielberg is currently
executive producing a snowpiercer TV
series and created created terminated
the Sarah Connor Chronicles oh they
brought him and they brought him in
that's sweet that's good and smart not
even like what kind gestures [ __ ]
smart smart cuz he's very smart to be
fair he's written more about Sarah
Connor
he's written a character more than
anybody else anybody else in the world
that's good you guys alright I'm um I'm
in the bag for this yes yes yes yes you
get all dirty money takers but I'm happy
to give my money for [ __ ] like this this
is goo I get behind man look if the
government wants to take like [ __ ]
half my paycheck as they always do but
each time they were like here's a movie
that you would really I mean if you
weren't to tie the me and then the
result of that tie is awesome nerd [ __ ]
alright better than some other stuff
well said do that story we'll do this
story they're making another Halloween
picture that day
no it's a different one superfast
version was at the club version that is
he John Carpenter composed music for his
Halloween films into to to to to to to
to but yes there's another Holly
direction the first Halloween did or did
not direct a second oh I believe he did
directly the second Halloween third one
no no and then off it goes oh he did can
you look up if he did Halloween -
there's a part of me that thinks he did
mmm okay I think he might have produced
and wrote but I don't know if he okay
might be one of those like who's buried
in Grant's Tomb
or I could be [ __ ] high and he
directed it but we'll know in a second
well know in a second but they make them
they're making this one this new one
with carpenters producing it or God
fathering it and doing the music uh-huh
user and David Gordon Green is directing
it is directing it and has been
co-written by Gordon green and Danny
McBride the guy from Vice Principals
directed it I knew it Rick Rosenthal I
knew it yeah I'm [ __ ] he was a writer
and a producer as well I mean he was
there his influences all over he did the
score again but he if I remember I
remember my 80s horror correctly he was
not the director of record fair and on
Halloween I wonder why there's a
documentary I saw online the other day I
want to stop and watch called like
Halloween like that looks back that's
sure they ripped it from a DVD but yeah
so it's Denham McBride David Gordon
that's a plum house production oh what a
great [ __ ] way we'll wait but what
wait what wait what what yes and Miramax
and Miramax
yeah cuz co pro cuz Miramax Harvey and
Bob will Bob Weinstein he's that no
Halloween for rent forever but the real
news is nothing they're making a
Halloween movie it's not even that
carpenter's executive pitter sync it's
not the dynamic Brian David Gordon Green
or do you had me at Sean carpenter the
real news is that Laurie Strode is
striding back in to the Halloween
franchise you had me again at this the
scream queen herself
Jamie Lee Curtis Jamie Lee Curtis Manish
coming back to talks of franchise that
made her famous in the first place she
was our eighties scream queen she was in
every [ __ ] movie which wasn't the case
really but she was in a lot of them she
was a lot of them and you know again
she's got genetic cred on being a screen
cream mom gets stabbed in the shower yes
in a movie called crazy guy was her mom
Janet Lee was her mom Jamie Lee Curtis
with Tony Curtis Buena day Jamie Lee
Curtis you know I don't need to tell you
she is she'd been on that [ __ ] show
the last few years Green Queens indeed
and she's the queen of the screen Queens
and she's been selling [ __ ] yogurt
that's good for your [ __ ] last couple
of years heavier but now she's control
made her famous these pipes are clean in
the hands of some people that give a
[ __ ]
absolutely she tweeted last week same
porch same clothes same issues forty
years later
headed back to happy filled one last
time for Halloween haha [ __ ] I love
the story of Halloween and I love the
the I didn't follow it quite as deep
though you know once it was a lot of
movies without John Carpenter's
involvement indeed but there was one I
believe where Laurie Strode dies I think
she dies in falls backwards on Halloween
h20 20 years later I think is maybe the
h2o movie the one that Bob did indeed
Amanda mention she comes back once for
Halloween Resurrection is that what this
movie's called no no that was in 2002
she came back for killer in Halloween
are they ignoring those and this is uh I
don't believe they are really I don't
believe they are there's a long dick
history on these movies about 26 these
Halloween pictures there's a little girl
for a long time right it's like the I
think they are the most honored the
continuity while still fortunately own
path I love Halloween movies so I love
the John Carpenter Halloween movies you
know I liked the first Rob Zombie one
the second one was alright better than I
could [ __ ] do I'll be honest with
these like he's got these visual stuff
as you should going on but but you know
these are close to my [ __ ] heart so I
like that they got carpet or evolved
yeah carbon had some really good things
to say about the two Bassett David and
Danny both came to my office with jason
blum and share their vision for me with
me for the new movie end Wow
they get it I think you're gonna dig it
they blew me away I might even do the
music maybe it could be kind of cool and
you'll get to see it in theaters on
October 19th 2018 so this shit's over a
year away yes you're in a month away my
[ __ ] are we talking about this because
Jamie Lee Curtis say yes good point
all right that's why now let's not think
of this anymore
because that's a [ __ ] year away year
away hit me with trailer in the summer
alright that's not news I like that I
thought it was on the verge alas last
lady we're going to talk about the
fictional lady yes this is a great idea
lady [ __ ] I think this is a great idea
tell me what it is Sabrina the Teenage
Witch it's getting spun coming back out
of Riverdale now have they introduced
the character on Riverdale will they
introduce the character this season I
mean I think the way it's gonna work is
it can work the same way that when they
introduced the flash and arrow it'll be
there'll be an episode that introduces
Sabrina doesn't spin out to her own show
that's smart this is a good idea because
they're not they're doing your mom's
[ __ ] Sabrina or your [ __ ]
grandpappy Sabrina no no I'm the Sabrina
they're doing they're calling this the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina tell them
why because the telemark the tone that
they're going for is Rosemary's Baby and
the Exorcist all right hold on did you
hear that how's the sound of blab maybe
how many mounts and I have two ounces of
[ __ ] just liquid life hitting the
inside of my gorge that is a good
[ __ ] idea man like to take Sabrina
and not be silly with it no you know you
better hide your spell Sabrina and her
witchy aunts and [ __ ] and make like
[ __ ] dark [ __ ] out of it totally a
girl who's got a wrestle with her own
inherent duality of being both a teenage
girl and a witch you know while trying
to stop the forces of evil in Riverdale
to some demon to others right
I think this is great [ __ ] idea this
gives them a chance to have a Buffy all
over again
yes which but don't be silly don't Misa
Buffy don't silly sometimes and you know
doesn't everyone have to crack [ __ ]
wise no you don't have to make jokes or
pop-culture references to leave that to
those of us who that's all we got you
guys can tell [ __ ] stories about
creepy [ __ ] witch kids and satanic
sacrifices this this could be amazing it
really I know it's a CW show but [ __ ]
like it could still be dark but it's
coming from the dudes like it's coming
from Roberto agree Riverdale Berlanti
productions and Warner Brothers TV and
like that's that team seems to do some
pretty good [ __ ] and this the I I'll be
honest with you this I find this more
enticing than Riverdale I'm like oh my
god take Sabrina and turn it into like a
[ __ ] story of like you know she's
really battling a [ __ ] the forces of
hell yeah like I'm not so much for the
kind of like late-night soaps that's not
my jam but if you're gonna add this
ain't me trying to get a job but can I
get a job give this brother job I would
totally direct up so do that oh my god
[ __ ] satanic Sabrina darkness
darkness imprisoning me although I see
absolute horror I cannot move I cannot
cool roll in pain I'm gonna wash beena
Teenage Witch she's no longer the
Teenage Witch it's just gonna be the
chilling of inches of Sabrina she's
probably gonna be teenage yeah maybe I
have to [ __ ] put that yeah that just
sounds too cutesy this is a good [ __ ]
idea I celebrate this yes I celebrate
this and look look if I know the CW kids
Melissa Joan Hart will be in it
somewhere
Oh she'll be the principal of a school
bang done [ __ ] get it he knows he knows
that's how I that knows this guy all
right so that's fantastic [ __ ] yes
when's this happen next week next season
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
47 only tell me things in like three
week in criminal little breadcrumb trail
nothing to truly but you know what that
gives me a reason to live I'll stick
around and watch Sabrina be done like I
said I can satanic princess and [ __ ]
she's like I'm fighting my father and
her father's [ __ ] devil maybe I'm
like look I'm you guys come up with it
but just that's pretty yeah you can have
it if you want it [ __ ] yeah more devil
they're saying The Exorcist in
Rosemary's but yeah they're doing it
dude there's Satan's gonna be involved
in this
what if Melissa Joan Hart is the devil
not like that no not so much that I like
there's the principle that's a good idea
maybe the devil know maybe an aspect of
the devil like the kindly woman teacher
and [ __ ] but then inside of her is the
devil inside maybe you don't you have
her always be the devil but you get
introduced use the devil where the devil
was the [ __ ] principal your high
school but you never say the devil until
like that smells like Buffy to me you
know what I'm saying like and I say and
everything wrong with that but I just I
want this to I just want this to be like
[ __ ] Syria like this should be like
Angel Heart the series on CW don't you
think like wouldn't that be chilling and
[ __ ] like with us chilling that I
want Lisa Bonet is the devil [ __ ]
she works she's every dime unless [ __ ]
yes
Lisa Bonet is a devil that's mr. bill
ante my sometime boss yeah oh my god I
want in on this in fact I'm waiting for
him to call me call him after the show
yeah I think I'm gonna email I want in
this is looking badass right well ante
at aol.com take my shot in the dark all
right so this is a great idea
there was three ladies ladies ladies
ladies as promised was the last story of
a bob subdued it was dude the director
of thor ragnarok this movie looks
[ __ ] phenomenal can't wait this movie
like honestly it's [ __ ] cat it's one
of these cats where I look at a [ __ ] and
I go yeah I'm a director like that movie
looks directed that's got some vision
behind it
it's got curvy backgrounds and [ __ ]
can't wait for this movie and his name
is take away TT which is
maybe the most fun director's name ever
to say look a that where is he from New
Zealand New Zealand
he's a Kiwi that I I think that's not a
slur did we just lose an entire island
nation sorry
well you lost us by calm Asylum agent
Mike we're not taking the hobbits to war
so you neither of us nailed that accent
I got close though you did you got coast
to the movies about the [ __ ]
middle-earth
I had no accent all right so foxy is
takeaway tt this guy he did what we do
invasion of the pickle people no was the
movie called the winter hunter the world
of people hunt to the hunt of the
wilderness yes it had or for Damien omen
three in it Sam yes well done and he
also did what we do in the shed what we
do in the shadow it's sort of faux
documentary about vampires which is like
[ __ ] they try to sell me every time I
go on iTunes it's always like you know I
must have liked something that they were
like y'all thought I love this I'm like
hey man
slow down don't pressure me I mean I
watched Twilight every night to go to
bed yeah
but this movie I can't wait to see his
[ __ ] thor ragnarok but he is starting
to talk about when his next thing is
gonna be and he's in discussions with
Warner Brothers to take on Akira the
live-action adaptation of the Japanese
both manga oh the next show yes Akira
he's doing Akira they've been trying to
do this for years
they really have like Leonardo
DiCaprio's Appian Way production has
been trying to mount this for a good
long time like there was once about a
seven where he was gonna star in it and
they can Reese is gonna be in it then
Kristen Stewart might be in it then it
was gonna be directed by the Hughes
brothers I'm not entirely sure who she
was one of the guys who produced cop-out
with me Mike and Ray they were scout and
couples going back a couple summers now
six summers ago New York because
like Warner Brothers gonna rush into
production on a cure and then it wound
up pulling the plug and stuff but this
one I mean I'd give it to him hi I'll be
honest I feel like a Kyra is
impenetrable to me I mean I remember
sitting there at the Film Forum in
Manhattan watching the cartoon back in
the day before the Internet's laserdiscs
DVDs and streams and stuff and you know
I was like boy it looks amazing but like
story it's me
didn't hit me in any particular like I
[ __ ] love this beautiful to look in
but I mean I kind of like it but it's it
goes weird [ __ ] places that that
sometimes don't make any sense but
that's also part of what Japanese anime
does so do you think he'll do a faithful
adaptation
I mean they've in every iteration of the
script so far they have removed it from
Tokyo if it'd been me Oh Tokyo yeah the
war and now it's neo Manhattan so right
away so right away I bet you this guy
takes it back to neo Tokyo I think you
know there always been an issue even
before like things like whitewashing you
become tip-of-the-tongue in Hollywood
circles of sanitising this in a way that
removes the cultural edges from it right
and the idea brings somebody like take
away TD on who is mindful of those
things you're still in a world in which
Warner Brothers have been testing Dane
DeHaan and Michael Pitt and Garrett
Hedlund and Kristen Stewart Oh for the
furtively here apart yes for the leaders
as Tetsuo cañedo
yeah but Akira Akira is this kid they
find in this there's military
sort of testing a hospital who's got the
crazy superpowers and
the government has been trying to
engineer another person like Shakira
since to make it a sort of living weapon
and Tetsuo is the subject they get
closest to but the power they give him
eventually warps his mind in his body
and so the end of the movie is his buddy
cañedo trying to rescue Tetsuo from
himself who's got like crazy if I can
flush arms and his blow and shut up it's
mine telekinetic power psychic fire all
of that stuff you've already done a
better job of explaining it when I sat
there watching the theater I was like
nope don't understand this is crazy
pretty but I don't get it why is that
teddy bear giant and chasing people so
yeah who knows if this gets done I mean
it's again a director who's revolving
around it have been four directors
before that I think I bet you this guy
gets I bet she does it though I think
come on
look at that Thor movie give that guy
cure you let do it everything keep
everything right yeah okay there it is
man all the news
Arnon lady news told you about three
ladies and a man that's it now we're
done go home frat may not Batman that's
it for fat man bath that's over yeah man
that's all we got come back next week
we'll tell you some more [ __ ] well next
episode yeah until then I've been Kevin
Smith and I've been working my man I'm
Batman
tune in next time same fat time same fat
channel SModcast come or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith man a line no it's
right there
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]